here is donald trump at a mar-a-lago  event last night saying putin is smart  he's taken a country over for two  dollars worth of sanctions i'd say  that's pretty smart take a look at this  trump's  smart i mean he's taken over a country  for two dollars worth of sanctions i'd  say that's pretty smart trump is saying  yeah  it is smart it is smart trump's actually  responding to the people who said wow to  buck sexton trump said how smart putin  is that's crazy and trump is going it is  smart what putin's doing is smart now i  understand in this clip he's not saying  i support it but he's clearly enamored  with the authoritarian nature of putin  as we've known for years